foreign
to start a new adventure
Heroes awakened on a desolate planet
silent God set in our sky
and it wouldn't be long before an
ancient enemy shrouded in darkness
showed up at Humanity's door to destroy
us over the years Our Heroes which tape
a story far greater than anything we
could have imagined
players would explore deep into the
depths of Venus hunting a machine God
that controlled times said if you want
it I'll say in good ways of weaponry and
their pure causal abilities to stand
alone against monsters that took others
an entire Elite Squad oh PlayStation 3
PlayStation shoes
or only a select few emerged in
Victorious at dawn clutching the heart
of a dragon the best
but most importantly they bring their
friends and their family into this world
all right now Crews coming back together
we approach the final shape
we were about to embark
on the last expedition of Destiny's
first Saga so let's be clear about the
stakes
in the final shape
you will go inside the traveler the
journey will be difficult
and what awaits you on the other side of
this track is nothing less than the
deadliest entity we have ever faced
there will be no open betas square if
you want to let us know it's on the
internet telling you how to handle
what's to come whether you've been with
us from the beginning
joined us somewhere along the road
or looking at Destiny for the first time
anybody who shows up on launch day is
going to be greeted with this same
Uncharted World a vacuum sealed
experience begging for you to be the
first person to peel it open
so today is your invitation to go forth
and adventure
so just a new planet heard
um
you're ridiculous
guaranteed will be a circle
after all these years
we never talked about it
why I brought you back
that's true
why you were chosen
I was the chosen one
all right
getting that warlock it's always a
warlock getting dealt with I know
Maybe
brought the glass with the galley it was
just
a deep Stone [__]
after all there he is
oh I know him
despite
might be our last
so I'm asking you
one please
to rise
they got everybody
what is that
something actually some some Titan's
gonna get it's ridiculous pre-order now
all right be right back
this is a momentous time in Destiny
history we've been building to this
moment for the last 10 years
the final shape is the conclusion to
that Journey this is a moment in gaming
that as a developer you just don't get
very often Guardians and allies are
finding the biggest threats that the
Universe has ever seen in this big
culmination of the light and darkness
Saga
when we were thinking of what the final
shape could be it had to be a lot of
different things it needs to pay off
this epic confrontation with the witness
that we've been setting up for years it
has to bring you closer to your allies
in the Vanguard it has to be this place
that like makes you feel nostalgic for
the entire Journey you've been on
when we were resurrected by ghosts at
the very beginning of the story we
didn't know why what it was for this The
Traveler is asking us for help
and it's our responsibility to protect
every living thing in the universe
when we first start the final shape we
are finally able to go through the
portal that the witness opened in the
traveler at the end of lightfall
inside is the pale heart of the traveler
that is the stage for a showdown with a
witness
the witness has the darkness it has
always had a connection to it
the pale Heart Of The Travelers what is
trying to use to gain connection to the
light so with both it can enact its
final shape
the witness looks around and sees a lack
of purpose no meaning it wants to fix
all that so it's trying to put the
universe into this Frozen Perfection
where everything's just exactly how it
thinks it's supposed to be that is the
final shape
if we're going to defeat the witness
it's going to take everyone
failure is not an option we're going to
need the Vanguard all of our allies and
all the Guardians to Rally together and
be brave in the face of Oblivion
in the final shape we're going to answer
questions at the grandest scale but what
I find really interesting is that it's
also a very personal Journey
where we deepen our relationships with
these characters that we've known for so
long icora our ghost gets a reconnect
with Cade six so like while there's this
great conflict and everything going on
around us and Stakes of just
unimaginable Heights it's still at the
end a story told around campfires by a
bunch of companions who have been
fighting together for hundreds of years
[Music]
has opened up to confront it and stop
the final shape
inside the traveler is this infinite
vast unknowable
Edward Lanning on the pale heart which
is a function of really what is inside
the traveler
the pale heart is weird
it's a little strange it makes you feel
a bit uncomfortable and it is also just
so cool and artistic in the best way
it's cool
the witness entered well ahead of any
Guardians and so it's had time to kind
of shape what's there when our Guardian
enters the rest of the pale heart starts
getting shaped also around what we've
experienced
this is the traveler recreating the
world in front of you as it saw on your
journey
one of the most memorable locales from
Destiny's past is the D1 Tower it's
really a labor of love from the destiny
team the final shape means so much to
everyone who's building it and I think
players are really going to be able to
see that
[Music]
the pale heart is our very first linear
destination that we've ever done I would
love it if players felt that they began
their journey in a place of safety
and feel it escalate in danger in
surrealness because there is this
beautiful evolution of the space
they see things that are more and more
wrong as they begin to go towards the
witnesses monolith it's kind of this
omnipresent foreboding thing off in the
distance
the weirdest things happen as you get
closer to the monolith in the form of
reshaping
kind of like deconstructing things and
putting them back together
just
wrong
the sense of scale you get out there
like as you're exploring these space and
you're jumping on these reshaped cuboids
of Earth you feel tiny as a guardian you
feel alone you feel like you are not the
force to be ready
you're not the god Slayer right now
you're just this little person jumping
from these massive pieces to massive
pieces
one of the things that we really try to
also capture is that the witness keeps
throwing everything it has at you and so
you're going to fight these new enemies
the subjugators what no enemies
of the newer unit you're going to be
facing in the final shape oh
they have an enhanced power set
they look like baby ropes Chasers
there's like the chickens entirely new
to the battlefield which is kind of this
element of control
he's throwing Crystals at you freezing
you in place tangling you up
the campaign and only the campaign it's
the most important thing in the universe
at that moment you have to stop the
fight
and for that we do need the help with
our allies and so we're going to make
sure that the core Vanguard team gets
back together
and cave
the campaign is just the start of the
pale heart after you've reached the
monolith and finished the campaign we
open up the entire destination and so
the entire pale heart is going to react
to you and what you are doing
raid
get it yeah the big bosses so it's only
natural that when you are going to
confront the witness you're going to do
that in the race they did it right they
did it right they did it right
I think that's what like really
disappointed me with sabbathume
yeah but she wasn't dead though
that we all know that was a fake out but
I'm just saying her traveler I felt like
her race this allows us yeah but that's
disrespected the raid itself though The
Rook rate was good it just absolutely
not issues with it but something that
turns you into it did it give us a whole
new enemy and a whole lot of things and
then one of the best Aesthetics but I
feel you though I know where you're
going with it is
doubling the amount of projectiles your
grenade almost being oh which one in the
birds
let's go yeah
applying Scorch when they're shooting
the new solar warlock aspect when I cast
my Rift it is going to create this
little solar Soul
snitch snitches again stitches we got
the best snitches of the ball like team
let's go we got informants
Twilight
Arsenal Titans getting what they're
getting that's not like typing sounds
like every layered
someone's another one looks at a
different group of enemies throws it and
when these axes fly through the air they
stick into the ground or an enemy do
their void gravity thing where they like
a bunch of energy
it doesn't destroy the ax the ax sticks
around and you and your allies can go
and pick up that sure you can pick up
things on enemies
insane to me the boy Titan aspect and
hold my grenade button to consume my
grenade and turn it into this Captain
America more damage it takes the more it
charges up and then I can release
this big black panther that deals
massive damage three black panther they
got the reflect joint
is all about finding the shortest
distance between two points the hunter
kind of rears back takes this knife and
throws it across the world and then is
able to Blink to its position do the
Slime oh that sounds just like saying
anyone nearby only great thing about
that is not just you do it once but
you're able to do it three times along
with devastating attacks each time you
do it
um
take our staff we twirl it in the air
which propels US upward it creates this
first
it almost makes it feel like you're
playing a fight oh he gave us some
effect combos that you're chaining
together
that sandbox to the next level the more
aspects we have the more capable we are
to do that it feels like you're like
riding the lightning you know like that
instantaneous like PVP going to be very
fun
it
we've got legendaries we've got perks
we're always cooking up stuff we're
always playing is like really
interesting you know we're taking
inspiration
desolation which is this exotic pyramid
Fusion rifle it has the really
intriguing property of a pre-order yeah
this will be the first time
yeah
you gotta come back home
what if you could harness the the might
of the traveler you know we had a moment
where we saw that traveler beam cut
scene I know people on weapons went I
kind of want that you're like that is
Incredibly Dope oh
bring back these iconic Destiny ones but
really turn it into something that feels
unique in Destiny too we have to bring
stuff into the cold this is an exotic
rifle and dragon's breath
we have new weapon sub families coming
broadening what existing weapons can be
really like bordering on exotic
functionality so for example
this fires tiny slow-moving Rockets they
hit very hard
[Music]
they have a mixture of regular weapon
and rocket launcher stats we're also
doing a new support weapon sub family
the support Frame Auto rifle is a type
of legendary Auto rifle it'll let you
switch seamlessly from firing at enemies
to Healing your allies
I'm really really excited to bring it to
Dungeons and keep my team alive honestly
um just desperate to help us carry those
dudes it doesn't seems
they're getting this new stuff for a
little Nerf later because people can
play the two Ops ideas which we're
pretty excited about
somebody said rest in peace
to do that you've got a lot to cover
oh oh oh
let's get it put your drinks out that's
me so
vegetables
hey you two oh he got his music go
swinging one of my favorites
this is
anyone want to hug love this song Oh my
map worst case scenario you die but who
knows maybe you won't
fight you rock off my back classic he
held Dusty though
I forgot
him that was how they introduced Destiny
too yeah
in this moment where we're driving to
the end of the light and darkness Sago
it's great to see Kade like return to
this world at this moment with all this
change about to culminate it only makes
sense he gets to come back to this
standing enemy the witness Cade is the
quintessential Hunter his presence cast
such a long Shadow over the story of
Destiny whether it was when he was alive
or when he was dead what Kate goes
through in this journey how he serves as
a catalyst for the other characters the
events that are uncovered to have
brought him back this is how the story
had to end there was no end to the light
and darkness Saga that didn't have Cade
here alongside his friends to finish
Hunter
once we started digging into the nature
of the pale heart I think that
crystallized Cade's role as a guide Kate
is Virgil and he's our guide through
this out of the place Kate is the one
who is the most appropriate person to be
the God because that's his job that's
always been his job it just feels so
natural for Nathan to be back in the
middle I feel amazing to just see him
slip back into the role like without
missing a beat instantly In the Flesh or
metal as it were cage the group is
always Zavala and ikora together having
him back puts them a position of
questioning where they've been and what
they've done without him you think about
the journey that zaval has been on and
how he's been taken down this dark path
and you think about the weight that's
been on ipora having to hold the
Vanguard together having Cade's voice of
levity and brightness that he brings I
can't wait to see that first scene where
he comes back
iconic at least we have each other
we want people to take away that sense
of reunion and that that idea of like
the gang being back together for this
moment
I'm here now
wherever the hell here is
bungee stores still under maintenance
Guardian
the witness posed as a dire threat
and the witch queen holds the answers oh
this season this season but only if we
contest we need her
um
oh
hey yo full on hive
hey yo
okay you now wield Hive magic
and have entwined it with your light
no I thought the Spire Guardian
and open the way to our
tithesis yeah it's next season isn't it
yeah but let them know fear
she looked old the deck of Whispers And
they do whisper
oh this season looks lit I'm not gonna
look I like it looks good oh no I do
think I think the rain is the season
that's why I think too isn't it a
reprise
they should probably tell us which one
it is
theme
look that looks like the place where you
fight Corona
there she is evil I heard that voice oh
we're finally gonna kill her
bro you haven't been playing you better
go to the Deep go to the Deep you gonna
learn so much about this evening oh
that's now today let's go
seasonally which is our opportunity as
players we've been annihilating and
breaking Hive spells and now we finally
get to cap I'm like at the end seven
weeks
that means we have to go find amaru her
ghost she's like not so fast we've got a
bigger problem first oh and that bigger
problems name is sibo around if we fight
her she only gets stronger Eris has an
idea it's a really it's a really good
it's a wild ass idea yeah she determines
like well the best way to fight fires
with fire we are channeling all of that
energy that we're creating by going
through by eliminating enemies and we're
tithing to our friend aerys
what does it mean for the characters the
player to kind of like be like
sabbathing and that's where we went down
the path of having Hive errors we want
to extend that magical fantasy against
the player then that ability to have
overwhelming magical power that risk and
reward into all of our activities and
systems experiences and so that's what
led us to come up with things like deck
of Whispers
that creates amazing synergies with your
build credit with Buffs and the
activities they can then choose these
cars at will whichever ones they want
and then that really leans into the car
games you actually are getting cards
that you can then use those words on the
battlefield and change the way you play
I'm such a sucker for dick building like
being able to like bring that element
into Destiny Gameplay has just been like
oh yeah oh it's really fun
two brand new seasonal activities coming
with Season of the Witch we've got
Alters of summoning and Sabbath Inspire
Sabbath inspires our new three-player
offensive you're doing a lot more with
the loose and Hive magic but it's got a
high amount of combatant density it's
got additional Random Encounters that
you can come across the witch Aspire
itself is having to inspire it was like
her reliquary for all these different
magical experiments as she was learning
the light you're there in order to learn
as much as you can in order to become a
master spellcaster right to become like
sabathune
the altar summonings activity is really
exciting because you can spend like 20
minutes in it or you can spend two hours
in it it's a three player experience hop
in and hop out of as you're going
through this activity you're filling the
tithing bucket as that tithing bucket is
filled up you'll get progressively more
rewards and then finally at the end
it'll cash out and you'll get a whole
mess of Rewards
we really wanted to make sure that there
was a home for any exotic Mission
content coming in Seasons after the year
has passed and so we developed what
we're calling the Exotic Mission Rotator
right away we're getting pressage Vox
obscura and operation serif field this
is some of the most fun content the team
has making it's some of the content the
fans and players of Destiny love the
most the most exciting thing outside of
just the missions themselves is that
every time we put a mission inside of
that Rotator the Exotic that comes
alongside of it will become craftable
I like press it yeah
we have a brand new Vex uh Lo-Fi PvP map
coming it's really exciting it's got a
bunch of really tight gameplay
experiences we want to make sure that we
focus the combat a little bit more
oh wow we really wanted to make sure we
had it anyway your shoulders shoulder
more often there's not as much deep
sight lines that you're interacting with
and a lot of the flow of the map is
actually built around this like kind of
central pillar of the Vex Network that
you're you're orienting around and
there's also some modes too right we've
got a new PVP game mode coming that's
all about relics it's about multiple
relics so it's not just one like The
Scorch game mode from the past so we've
got the shield coming from vaulted glass
we've got the spear back from season of
the Risen and we've got the Scythe from
season haunted yeah so you're going to
be reaping Guardians with that thing
it's a lot more tactical gameplay it's
all about running around the map
claiming these Relic dispensers and then
grabbing them in order to push for
victory
I will take what I need
the words in my throat are the weapon in
my face we were feeling pretty Heidi
this is obviously
thinking about like what's a good reason
uh this very high road I don't know
roaches and here we go let's get that
dungeon out the way
there I go there it is
maybe it's less dungeony now
well weapons are coming back
because whisper exists but it'll be
interesting
oh I saw a deco Chasm I like that
they're giving you the glowing armor yes
let's go
to my phone
oh what's that
heading into the final shave we really
want to Rally all Guardians at the end
of the light and darkness Saga we want
to reduce
as well as catch people up on key story
great and easy time connecting with
other players
in the final shape we're trying to find
ways to make power more influences
entry it's going to make it easier for
players who have not been able to jump
into game easily because they were
helped by the challenges in binding for
the power levels that are required
that's going to be happening starting
with the final shape is there are going
to be a certain number of activities
that are going to be power fixed so it
doesn't matter kind of what power level
you are going into it you're always
going to be able to approaches you're
going to be tears of difficulty that you
can do things that are just meant to be
experienced a certain way things like
Nightfall strikes that will still have
power enabled and that's where we're
really going to focus the whole power
climb the raids the contest modes that
everybody loves to engage with that
experience is fundamentally going to be
staying the same I'm excited for this
because I think there will be a lot more
clarity for players in terms of
understanding the relative difficulty of
things where they sit now in the
Spectrum one way that we're trying
trying to do that is making it easier
for new players to engage with you so
we're introducing something that we're
calling fire team power you can actually
bring your friends along to play any
Dungeons and raids in the game without
having to wait them to be at a certain
power level the person with the highest
power in your fire team is actually
going to bring all the others close to
their power level which means that
there's no barriers really for any other
Guardian to join you in this high level
content when it's combined with fire
team finder it also allows you to find
strangers people you've never played
with before and have that same
experience that's all regardless of the
power level of you and the rest of the
people in your fire team fighting
finders the new feature that's coming in
season 23 aimed at helping connect and
find other people to complete the best
and most aspirational content in Destiny
we have well you know why they put games
to be able to say well this is my place
now I'm really chill
I'm just really here to happen with me
a little bit more personalization a
little bit more about what they're about
I think what's really great about it is
with this launch we're also looking at
including inclusion tags as an example
the one of the inclusion tags that we
have are for colored blind players
hopefully the inclusion tags will bring
players closer to finding their
community and and even closer to the
people that they're playing with so once
a listing goes Live players will be put
into a listing Lobby where players can
gather they can communicate with each
other so we wanted to make it do what
Xbox has had for a long time now
basically yeah
as a gamer who's typically more solo I'm
especially excited about this because it
really is about helping reduce that
anxiety and burden that comes with
trying to make a new connection
the feature are coming out today that
I'm incredibly excited about is timeline
Reflections essentially what we have
done is we've went back to previous
expansions and pulled out missions that
we felt really represent key narrative
Feats within our story we're going to
have a mission for forsaken mission for
Beyond light as well as a mission for
which Queen
yeah
we took your light away
to like identify like okay this is why
it's important
here are the people
a really big one that's really timely
for final shape is Cade's Last Stand
from forsaken
oh so you gotta you gotta wait on a
rotator to play maps you paid four years
ago
it's just the right time to introduce
features that are going to allow those
players to Jump Right In Progressive
free I've already paid for
it for free now
it's free for everybody
what comes next
the episodes
and the new way we're going to tell
stories moving forward what's really
important about episodes is that it's a
really big shake-up to what we've been
doing instead of providing Four Seasons
a year you are going to get three larger
episodes oh the first three episodes
echoes
Revenant okay more media controversy
it's coming right after the final shape
episode the theme for the year is going
to be all about the consequences of the
final shape I think what's really the
Cornerstone of the episode
3x structures
the ax act as these anchors for us to
introduce road map new artifact mods new
activities there's gonna be New Missions
coming around the court there'll be new
story moments in every single one of
these acts we're actually providing more
cinematic style experiences throughout
the final shape year and the episodes
with it than any of the seasons we've
ever developed before these new stories
are actually playable
and you can experience
this is your first one you're going to
be able to basically
content is Big epic moment is that we
get to innovate the game we get to move
it if you think about it
it's all about more weapons more loot
more often and it really provides the
team with a platform to go much deeper
into the themes and Fantasies and story
oh God
can you guys hear me yeah
any individual episode
today I'm so excited to see what the
narrative team can do with this kind of
new platform of Storytelling episodes
provides this awesome foundation for the
future of Destiny we're moving into the
next Destiny too
bad in many ways it's the opposite we're
leaning in we're putting
episodes
me too throughout the year
you do try to buy something that fat you
try to buy that collection I want it
immediately what makes a gun
a guardian
devotionally
bravery
we know that we were chosen for a reason
by something greater than ourselves yeah
wait guardian we say it's the uh
Guardian the wall is the reason that
people start trying to mess with the
Guardians it's because they got tired of
killing the same person over here it's
as of Allen dude we've killed him like a
hundred times
we are the final line that holds the
second collapse
oh that's a forsaken every Hunter
what is this the Guardians say
to Wilson inspires bravery
bravery inspires sacrifice
leads
the line between light and dark is so I
wonder what's gonna happen with chrome
very yeah
never heard much of them also Kay's
probably not happy with him together
that's gonna be interesting because I
didn't see him in that portal either
dark
trust me you've heard the stories of the
Traveler's sacrifice
of Darkness descending upon Humanity
[Music]
thank you
There Is No Escape
it's going to be an exciting year for
Guardians we get to make good on a
promise that we made way back in 2014.
there was classic rock blasting yeah
fire team racing across our solar system
and at the end simple message
come Legend
today you've got a glimpse at how we'll
be cementing your Legend in this
upcoming year
we're gonna be heading inside the
traveler experiencing a destination
unlike anything we've ever built before
we'll face the biggest bad we've ever
made and we'll do this all alongside a
streamlined progression system allowing
us to easily play with friends and any
content in the game and as the dust
settles in the final shape we're going
to continue our Legends in echoes it's
Destiny's first episode in a new face of
Storytelling for Guardians with brand
new conflicts born from the resolution
of the light and darkness Saga
these First episodes are just the
beginning but if you're chomping at the
bit to see how the light and darkness
Saga is going to kick off the future of
Destiny 2. we've got a ton of great
content for you to jump into today going
live after this we've got Season of the
Witch
with a new story new weapons new armor
new activities and new PVP content all
alongside a series of story catch-up
missions allowing any of your friends to
jump into the game and get up to speed
on what's happening in this world
then next week a brutal reprisal of
crota's end is going to join the ranks
of our aspirational content
I can't wait to see you all in the
throne world as we learn more about the
final shape
and how we can stop it
getting marketing team
yeah they're really good at that do not
be afraid
selfish
fight
hey I remember a lot of software at the
world like a lot of crowds games
one last time yeah
yeah yeah
collector's edition reveal yeah
is that the original tower yeah
they giving us the towel
day one like I think having it be the
tower
mentor
I can't wait to go to back a DPS podcast
when you go live that's gonna be
listening messages
we're always trying to push them so
we've been at the door
just sort of make this experience as a
whole
um really special it's sort of the
perfect symbol of Destiny let's go for
it
you got our courage about let's get it
here we come
[Music]
let's go
they got that's a mean looking poster
yeah that post is hot
so is that the that the guardian and the
right yeah that shirt yeah
website up yeah yeah you got to jump in
right now thank you guys want to be what
it feels we gave what it feels
where is that
I'll see give it a link DJ man come here
I'll sit right here
oh yeah and then you'll be a little
walking yeah get right in that go
you can see you are in line I'm in line
yo please notify what is my turn
I'm in
they got the little man walking
10 minutes to enter
I gotta wait
screaming oh screw you don't look happy
yeah
that didn't really grab me too much
what which part of it
the collector's edition okay I thought
you meant the whole thing I said oh no
he doesn't never buy Collective stuff
once you wanted something
I don't know man yes
collector's edition Xbox 275.
they said the bag
back
there is a full show where else
I don't know tell me tell me screen
it says it's starting soon it's still oh
okay there is a post oh yeah he did they
did say that yes thank you Spirit but
I'm also into the industry
it was a posto short though huh it says
starting soon
oh
check out now Hearts right now but it's
okay
it's real real tough out there
just I just feel it it's Gonna Hurt
don't worry you already go
yeah Forte's background's crazy
oh yeah
oh let's see this
hater
no UAE you're talking about you hyped
for Ark survival
you hit it that GT talking about you
hype uh survival oh man don't let me
find out let me find it let me come for
you and use the dusty hate to keep me
hate
[Laughter]
look at them you see what's going on
ah
oh
that's a lot for shipping I'm sorry how
much they want you shipping 50 bucks 25
a thing it should be free shipping
payment method
yeah see I'm I'm I'm trying I'm still
I'm still trying to figure out if I want
to commit for a year
[Laughter]
you gotta earn it back no they got to
earn about it yeah you're right
like they already earned you back oh no
I love what I said
nobody talking about I don't care what
no chat talk about how y'all can sit
here in place it's so good so be good be
good by yourself I'm good you're fine
you could be good I'm great I got like
Forte we gotta jump off the ship
eventually we might as well jump off it
now hold on go go jump off Google see
ghosts commit suicide do that commit
suicide I'm I'm having fun I am not
gonna allow Debbie down to talk to stop
my fun but y'all do y'all ain't no
Debbie down yeah I just yeah enough for
you
that's cool
needle
it's like more time it's like he's
insisting on uh that we're trying to
convince him not to play like no but I
didn't ask y'all like y'all I'm not
doing it I'm not doing it all right cool
don't do it I didn't ask you I'm doing
this so clearly y'all bombed it not me
what
49 000.
I am solo I'm coming for you now so he's
out here captain
and we had Ark survival right now steam
chart 49 000. impressive impressive I
didn't think that must be playing it but
um 49 000 people could current Destiny
at its Worst season where the game is
Dead Right Now 49 000 concurring
and that's good change at this
I'm sorry no you ain't lying you right
that's right so my game dead but got
more than the games
listen I never said Destiny was dead
yeah
so on there and taking a little shot so
I just go to the numbers I just wrote a
number that's what I do and the numbers
say that my day game is still more than
their thin game that's going on
I need the shirt
oh I understand for GM about the story I
mean this is going to be like the Epic
conclusion to the light in the darkness
Saga like players are finally gonna get
to go into the traveler confront the
witness like the stakes have never been
higher I'm just really excited to get to
watch everybody play it out
I don't know
anyway what about you Dan oh for me I
mean uh it's it's a lot about the supers
right like I just think we we have this
ability with these supers coming out to
shift the meta in a really exciting way
and like I just haven't played through
them and gotten some hands on them sorry
like no spoilers but like I think
they're they're they're gonna play in
all parts of the game so I think you're
going to see these in the campaign
obviously but you're gonna see these in
PvP and they really feel like that sort
of Pinnacle achievement of our Guardians
journey in a lot of ways so just really
excited to see the final product
yeah yeah for me I guess it's maybe
surprising it's the weapons I know like
shock yeah they make a lot of weapons on
Destiny too right um and so why are we
excited about the weapons this time I
think the team sort of really looked and
said what's core to Destiny right like
what's really important we said hey like
Destiny's at its best when you're
getting a bunch of new weapons and those
weapons are so exciting that they are
making it onto your character right away
they're like changing the way you play
so this is not just Exotics right it's
not just like I think it was alluded to
like what if golden gun was a sniper
rifle pretty cool sniper rifle
um I think it's also we talked about
these new you know weapon subtypes and
so
what's a support Auto rifle we've made
guns that heal before we've made Exotics
to do it well if we do it in a legendary
what needs to be different about it so
we can make this thing that feels as
useful to a fire team as someone
bringing Gala horn that feels as useful
as someone you know bringing Divinity
right and we know that's the bar that we
have to hit so we're looking at a bunch
of different things and saying okay
we're gonna make these guns and we're
gonna make a matter right we're gonna
we're gonna go out and you're gonna get
awesome stuff on you know the pale heart
I think we showed a little bit of it
there's like a sweet they look like a
deck of cards you go back and watch the
footage
um and there's a bunch of awesome stuff
coming in the weapons and so I think
we're really just trying to hit that
core like yeah right like the loot
should be awesome
absolutely yeah well me too
um so speaking of the pale heart the the
reveal it was said in the reveal the
pale heart destination is the first
linear destination ever done so can you
talk us through why it was decided to
make it work when your destination
yeah not sure how many uh folks uh have
been in algebra recently but if you're
like a linear please blind
what is the destination if you think
about it
these big public areas they're all
connected in a circle and then from
those areas there's little offshoots
they're little Alleyways that you can go
to
and that just didn't make sense for
going inside the traveler one because
the traveler is huge when we talk about
the pale heart we're saying you know
like
hey what if you were an alien you landed
on earth and the only part of Earth you
saw was like a parking lot in Montana
and you were like oh this place is huge
right like it's sort of like okay so
we're going to show you a really small
slice of what is inside the traveler and
then we said it needs to feel like
you're going somewhere important right
vast unknowable place okay well on one
end we've got the portal right and on
the other end we've got the witness
that's built this giant monolith and so
every single area that we've built is
built in a consecutive line from one to
the other so you travel through these
things and you can look back at once you
once more and if you need to go to the
next part you're not going into these
offshoots the dead end you are going to
where you need to be going it's really
focused on hey you're got a job to do
here so it's like tracking your journey
yeah yeah it definitely is okay cool
well that sounds insane so
super different that's what we go for um
during the Showcase it was also
mentioned that completing the campaign
would unlock the full destination and
then it almost like reacts as we
progress is that kind of what you're
hinting at or can you explain that a
little bit more yeah so I think two
things we want people really to Come
Away with thinking when they think about
one
this is a bit different in the way that
you experience the pale heart right away
so normally you might land on the throne
world and you do a mission and then
you're out with your Sparrow exploring
the throne world doing the missions if
you want to
be one of the final shape
you've got a job to do right and so it
is mission mission mission right and you
just go through and you say hey we've
got to stay focused on this thing when
you get to the end of that day one
experience everyone can sort of like
collectically collectively take a breath
collect themselves and then you just for
this realization
oh work inside the traveler right like
we should probably go see what that's
about and so the whole destination
unlocks for you and there's a lot of
things that are different about the pale
heart that are other destinations
I think we're gonna save some of those
juicy tidbits for what's different about
this destination and how it sort of
compares to what we've done in the past
uh but yeah it's a it's a pretty
different experience than even what you
might expect in somewhere like the
dreaming City and for real like we do we
do want to save some of these juicy
tidbits not just because it's fun but
because like I mean The Travelers just
been this inscrutable god-like sphere
that people have wanted to know more
about for so long and like this is their
opportunity to experience some of that
mystery and that's I'm excited to see
how that plays out well it's alive right
so what can you really expect
I think you know we talked about this we
showed a little bit uh the the section
that you're in it's shaped off of who's
there right and so who's been there so
cool the witness right the witness
messing stuff up yeah chilling right
there we're trying to knock on the door
we don't know how to get inside
um and you know and we're gonna make it
eventually and so it's got this both
really unique aspect to it and a bunch
of the Geo looks like stuff that you've
never seen before a bunch of these
places feel like you know this Heaven on
one side hell maybe in the middle
crazy Destiny surrealness at the end and
then there are these accents of like God
I'm not like a crazy Heavenly Beach you
see this giant ghost carp into a
mountain or you see the D1 Tower
erecting out of this and so you know
we're really excited to sort of give
people this like distilled Destiny
experience that still feels really new
when you're in there
so Dan we've got feedback from players
who wanted to learn more more about the
origins of the witness and and the veil
during the lifelong campaign rather than
wait until like later on in the seasons
uh so players have big narrative
expectations for the final shape how are
we taking this feedback and making this
the Epic conclusion that this first Saga
deserves oh yeah no I mean this is this
is the sort of fun of the challenge
which is the light in darkness Saga it
has been such a focal through line for
really most of Destiny's existence right
like it is this this epic story Joe was
just talking about let's get to know
some of that that sort of culmination of
experience inside the pale heart and so
this is
a spot where we have to really land that
that culmination in a satisfying way
right like there's there's a
confrontation that's been happening
there's a story that's been told this
part of the destiny world we have to end
really well and the players deserve that
the story deserves that and so there's
some things we're doing to to account
for that but in addition we have to set
up the next set of stories and we're
going to talk probably more about
episodes in a bit but like starting
after the final shape with uh with the
new the new episodes framework that
we're rolling out we're going to tell
all different stories and we'll learn
more about the world of Destiny moving
forward so that's the unique challenge
that we are taking very seriously and to
accommodate that we've done more I think
on the narrative side of the fence than
we've even done in the past you know
more significant writers rooms we've
brought in more folks from even other
parts of the studio to to really kind of
consult on this and make sure that you
know all of our fans who probably know
the destiny lore better than I do are
you know are getting the pieces and
answering answers to the questions that
they want answered unless we want to
save some of those questions for the
future stories that we're going to tell
um you know there's there's more to it
than you and you and the team have been
doing as well if you want to talk to
that yeah probably to steal a little bit
from uh Cosmos and Pica's questions and
give them the the note card shuffle here
and there
um I think one of the things that we
knew that was going to be challenging
about this is hey we're telling the
climax of the story we know that hey
when you get in the final shape in those
first moments we want you to feel like
okay
bungee delivered on This Promise like
delivered on This Promise of becoming
Legend delivered on like uh really
giving putting a bow on the traveler and
pyramid story The the thing that was
also important for us is like okay
they're gonna like confront the witness
like the biggest bad in Destiny
okay we I think you have to confront the
witness in the raid right like a version
of Destiny's chronological history where
like the witness was tough not quite as
tough as valka or right like it's
probably not a thing that our players
are going to be super happy about not
nothing I'm going to be happy about it
what we really think is this this day
one experience is sort of like the
uh penultimate episode or the you know
right before the season finale of your
favorite TV show and it really sets the
stage for hey this is exactly what's
going on in the world of Destiny the
stakes have never been higher you go
through a pretty epic journey and then
we say okay
now we have to have this raid beat and
so it's sort of a reverse uh
taken King if some of our people
remember that moment in the taken King
we delivered a thing or hey day one for
80 of our players they're like I dealt
with oryx and then for like 20 there was
this other thing that they could go do
have another experience with oryx right
and so for this one we say hey when
everyone to go really set up what's
happening in the final shape and then
for everyone right or we're not going to
get into that right
you should all wait for the rain right
like and we're gonna like
help make sure everyone is brought along
for the end of this journey I think it
takes a lot of our learnings from both
really classic experiences like crota
and oryx and sort of infuses them with
what we've been doing with things like
sabathune and kallus and like taking all
that lessons and saying okay I think we
can do this the right way yeah and also
just for something like this when you
when you complete the circle of the
story that we've been telling we want to
make sure that we're paying homage to
the things of the past and we're we're
talking through just so many of the
things that have made this story what it
is but also telling it in a way where if
you're coming into the final shape is
your first experience you can enjoy the
mission you can enjoy the campaign you
can understand what is happening right
but there's just a lot more if you have
almost decades worth of Destiny play
knowledge that you can look at so it
kind of sounds like that means I have to
play The Raid to get the full story
no
now while we're really excited make sure
y'all
I think the different part from our
strategy sort of is in the past was we
said hey there's something more for
those who raid there is a piece of the
story right that just that is told in
the ray there's a piece That's essential
um but it is definitely not going to be
a moment where only Raiders get to see
the end of light and darkness Saga right
okay
well that's good
so we carefully skirt around a thousand
plot points here
so
um we showed a glimpse of the new enemy
the subjugators are they going to be as
terrifying as the tormentors like what's
what sets them apart from uh from
previous enemies
yeah we we were running through some
questions yesterday just like this uh
spoiler alert we do practice a little
bit like we do we do think about this
um and I got in trouble because I said
several obscenities last time I did this
so I'm not gonna do that today uh on
stream who scolded you uh it could have
been anyone it could have been anyone
that scolded okay
um and so I I've been playing a lot of
final shape recently probably surprising
to No One um subjugators are very
different than tormentors tormentors are
sort of like this Kool-Aid man that
busts through the wall and is like
saying all right look at me right now oh
okay
um and subject eaters for us
they come out in these moments where you
feel like you have a battlefield full of
enemies and then you hear the pyramid
Screech sounds there's a sound
and a subjugator beams in and it's like
the ultimate sort of backfield tactician
right and they're doing things like
giving everyone uh around a little
pyramid buddies like you've been shot in
PvP with an arc sole like imagine tin
taken Scions and suddenly a sub Digger
what if you all had little pyramid
buddies you're like oh thanks and so
there's still these moments where you're
like
you might want to just hold on to your
super you might want to hold on to some
heavy ammo when you're playing through
the campaign just in case
through I think one other thing that
we've really learned from both
tormentors and light hive
is sort of building these sort of like
any units things that feel scary and
we're very careful in both witch Queen
and in lightfall to make sure and we
don't want to overuse these we don't
want this to become a thing where you
get a bounty and it's like kill 20 light
high oh wow they're just everywhere
um and I think we were striking the even
better balance now that we have a pallet
of these captains where it feels like
hey I'm getting these like really meaty
sandbox experiences
um and we know how to sort of engage
them in both the destination and the
strike and the mission so
um I'm really happy with a bunch of the
learning the team has been taking as we
continue to make these things oh totally
yeah my super basic take from having
played it is that like and I didn't know
how this was going to play out until I
experienced it Joe described it really
well but it's what I want from these
units as a player is I want that moment
of and insert obscenity here so Cosmo
doesn't yell at me
um but like and and the subjugator
absolutely delivers that in the same way
that I felt from the Tormentor in the
same way I definitely felt the first
time I saw the light Hive but just to
Joe's point it's a very different way
right like it is when it comes out like
I'm just as terrible worried for myself
it looks like Age of Empire four for
Xbox
you have to you have to approach them a
very different way so I think it's
important it feels very good to me at
least
because whatever he just described what
you were picturing is probably lighter
than what's actually going to happen
like everybody
had to say I'm picturing some yeah okay
yeah I'm a little nervous
um okay so Dan this is for you your
favorite or everyone's not yours
everyone's favorite Hunter cave six
assumingly back from the dead can we get
a little bit of the story on that I mean
I'll happily take this one so I love
talking about kids uh I mean here's the
reality we've been talking about this
all coming full circle and you know Joe
was talking about the campaign his
mission you have a mission there's a
thing that has to happen and like both
as players and developers it was just
hard to picture finishing this fight
without k-6 right and uh so you know so
we brought k-6 back and I'm you're going
to get less details than you want but uh
but but k-6 is back for this fight and
it was super important to us as you go
through to have k-6 Savala ikora on
comms talking through and I think the
most critical part of that is it's Kate
six with Nathan Fillion and uh I don't
know about everybody else but like Joe
and I were talking about this yesterday
and I think Joe said it really well
which is like when you're playing
through the builds as you're going
through at the moment Nathan's line
started actually coming through recorded
man it just hits different right like it
just felt it just changes the dynamic
for me as far as like what I feel about
what's going through the sort of
complexities of the story uh but the
part that's important I think to know is
that like this is Kate like Kate is back
hey is with you on this journey he is
your guide through the pale heart yeah
um and there's other stuff that we're
not gonna talk about just yet because I
want players to experience it but uh
yeah anything more you want to add there
it's just it's exciting no I will
probably say this a few times
we were like what is the
what's the final shape how are we going
to do this what's really important we
really wanted to make sure that this
experience felt like the most distilled
version of Destiny yeah like it's
Destiny dialed up to 11. it is the like
Destiny extract that if you were baking
with your you only need a few drops like
it's very potent
um and uh for us you know we we knew hey
we we've been planning this narrative
road map out for a long time we were
like okay okay we know we need to make
the best of this moment that we have
with Kade here
um but I think it was really again as
the vo starts to come in and you're in
these missions
oh that's like that's like Cade six
talking to me even I wouldn't say
everyone's favorite Hunter I mean might
have something to say about that but
yeah it just it really starts to be like
okay yeah this is this is that distilled
Destiny experience yeah I'm not
picturing Destiny extract on the bungee
store I don't know where it's foreign
[Laughter]
so we've been talking about final shape
let's talk about episodes
um we've seen some feedback from the
players uh that the seasonal model has
has gotten a bit predictable at times
and uh we just saw in the show yeah I'm
still in line
Cadence is getting refreshed with this
episode model can you talk us through
what episodes are and how they're going
to be different than Seasons sure yeah
so uh I mean let's let's start with sort
of what episodes are in the record right
I think the easiest way to think about
episodes is the natural right now
three years at this point
yeah really quality experiences three
months you know very fast Cadence really
move the story forward I think we've
told some great stories you know
introduce some new activities new
mechanics really moved everything
forward
but that made the experience somewhat
repetitive
um of like almost sort of by Design in a
certain way which uh which is now I
think stretched out to the end of its
like you know utility so episodes change
up the framework and change up the
delivery Cadence so there are three
episodes a year the first one we'll
start alongside the final shape and
parts of it will start a little bit
after we'll we can touch on that in a
sec
um but these three episodes are split
into three
and this means two things really one
that now what you're really looking at
is nine beats a year that are six weeks
six weeks apart and each of these beats
gives us an opportunity to materially
change the state of the game to clearly
move the meta forward introduce new
story introduce new weapons new perks
new activities
um and it doesn't have to be so
formulaic so it allows us to do what I
think Destiny does really well well
which is get a little weird at times
like you know throw I have some really
bad baseball metaphors I'm not going to
use but like like throw some curve balls
into you said you weren't going to use
the base one okay yeah
and it's going to be interesting to
about four people so we're not gonna do
that but like it allows us to to react
more to you know what else is going on
in the game allows us to to change up
the way we look at uh content delivery
in a way that I think is just strictly
better for all of us who are players
right like these six weeks the six weeks
in between major beats I think is a
really good way for players to you know
play Destiny in where within their own
lifestyle how it fits into the white
space of their life I think it allows us
to to introduce different things to try
some different things like I said make
it weird and really start to experiment
in a couple of places because of not
everything has to be there all at once
right at the top so I think I think what
episodes allows us to do is to not only
continue telling stories in a I think a
new and pretty interesting way but it
also allows us to just really amp up the
variety of the types of things that we
can bring and when we can bring them
into the game which uh which I think is
just going to be a great experience
absolutely what does that mean for the
reward track
yeah so uh one of the your most
interesting things that we're doing with
episodes is probably how they used to
start okay so for us
yeah when the final shape is happening
everyone in the universe is saying you
know what's important this whole thing
that's going on in the traveler right
now we've got to be really focused so
we wanted the episodes to be a reaction
to What happens when the final shape
resolves right
um and so this means both we don't want
to tell a competing story at the same
time and we want hey once the first
episode kicks off for it to be in the
context of what happens in the final
shape so the majority of the narrative
content the activity content really when
the episode begins
happens that reset after the raid
um however
right away we know there are some
systems that just need to be online so
the reward track you're going to be able
to get Red Death log into the game claim
it from the past uh I've been using it a
lot in play tests uh it's a solar weapon
can I say that so like
yeah somewhere from the weapons team
it's like oh
uh and uh yeah I think we're excited to
have that and there's there's even a few
steps you're going to be able to get uh
weapon Wise from the episodes themselves
we have another sub archetype
we haven't talked about what sub
archetype that is we might see it in
survive should I hear DJ's I think it's
kind of things yeah we're gonna be like
Oh I'm gonna like let me bring this
world first race so we're excited for
both of them available right away but
keeping that meat of that narrative
that's what he asked you you're going to
say everyone's on the same page if you
are in episode one you're hearing those
lines dialogue you're getting the story
beats here everyone is saying I mean you
did weird
today guys
now it's actually going to reset
um at every act so you'll have 100 ranks
for the First Act of each episode and
then 50 additional will be added for uh
for each subsequent act so 200 ranks
throughout the course of an entire
episode and uh and that length actually
allows us to add some more stuff to it
right yeah I think we're you know we
want to make sure that the those
additional ranks in Act 2 and act three
are really rewarding and so we've both
learned from our players like hey we
really value this can we get more of
this and so like great we got that and
then we're also just
going back to some old experiments one
of the things I'm really excited about
is oh yeah in the 30th Anniversary we
tried this experiment we're like we're
going to give everybody
tiger helmet right and it's like silver
and it glows and I'm like yeah and the
ornament
like maybe we should do that again maybe
that should be what's on the very end of
the past not only is there you know
unique
thing right now they always do that
right in time
to be taking a lot of learnings
feel different
what's going to happen though is when
Act 2 rolls around
it's a magic space appears at the top of
the artifact and a whole nother row
appears nice and so this is not meaning
you're going to get less in act one
you're gonna get the same amount you're
used to back two brings another row
whole new ways to modify the game and
act three another on top of that so we
really want these acts to feel like hey
it's not just that we're bringing new
activity it's not just that we're
bringing you know we are shaking up the
meta there's new rewards there's new
ways to play there's new nightfalls in
the rotation room all of this is sort of
what we're heading out it's like yeah we
love this idea of you know players
finishing the final shape an episode
kicking off and then just being a few
weeks away from like wait act two is
like weeks away you're like yeah yeah
it's like it's right around the corner
and then they're in act two and like
well act three is weak sweating yeah
yeah how can we make sure that Destiny
always feels like it's changing evolving
yep yeah it sounds like it'll be like
really refreshing yeah more often but
can you tell us what happens after the
first three episodes what's next with
Destiny two what are you trying to get
them so the the episodes are everything
our new stories
um you're gonna get less information
like like really move the story forward
in different ways and so one of the
things that we want to experiment with
is can we make these some of these
episodes more Standalone stories do they
have to all interconnect can you play
them in specific orders things like that
and so
um so starting yeah so after after the
the episode three the intention is to
continue rolling episodes forward and
keep telling different stories and take
whatever learnings that we get from the
first three episodes and start to evolve
the framework yeah and I don't think
Dan's gonna uh kill me here but we'll
we'll see so uh maybe keep the coffee
cup out of his hand and wait for a spit
taking
we got a lot of people most of them are
at home um I was going to point to the
other side of the office most of us work
from home now
um that are working on Destiny 2 and are
going to still be working on Destiny 2
after the final shape and so oh I'm not
going to kill you for that uh yeah it is
not just uh episodes like we know
there's a bunch of content and there's
different ways that we can get that in
the player's hand and those folks still
want to make that content like the
awesome stuff that we're sort of known
for and so
um again we'll be a little cool here
today
um but yeah to go back to what Robbie
was saying like hey wait we got some
more dread on the tires here and we're
we're excited to show you where we're
driving yeah and again to the what we're
saying before we think the episode model
with the 3x structure allows more like
flexibility for us to make some of that
cool content and make some different
content and I think the team is pretty
excited about that too so episode four
never mind three meteor maybe who knows
[Music]
yeah but even before we get into the
specifics like Destiny's just better
when you're playing with friends it's
better in groups it's better with the
fire team and so being able to build
that fire team and being able to play
the best content is the sort of
overarching goal for what we're trying
to do and yeah so we got fire team we
got fire team power we've got uh
timeline reflections
this is an update to your quest page
where we're like taking over that front
page and saying hey this is the big
Quest and here's another Quest that's
important and so we think
super important for our new players that
get inundated with a ton of content to
go see they're like wow what are what
are my friends focused on can I can I
make sure that's out this is great for
them it's also great for people that are
already playing Destiny in the like okay
I finished day one of they made a shape
and you're like I got a lot of which one
they made the TV show I'd actually want
to follow to be the main character
there's a group of you know I feel like
they've showed a lot of him in the past
looking and saying okay what's the
what's the next pain point for Destiny
players so we're really excited about
fire team power
um I think it's gonna neither him or
have a show dedicated
about getting their power up in their
light up
um but also allow you know
I've Got Friends that haven't played
Destiny a while and I would love to just
say to them hey just get in the game
whatever guns you have you're gonna
group up with me we're gonna do the
dungeon yep we're gonna go we're gonna
go play PVP we're gonna go do this thing
yeah okay
I think there's going to be this whole
new influx of Guardians in season 23
third thing they'll be like last week so
what's that all about right like I've
heard some things there's a dragon there
let's go like let's go and uh
yeah
there's a lot to change I wasn't
listening even if you access the content
so let's make it easier to access the
content yeah that's the biggest thing
for me is just that like
disregard it together
but in all seriousness like that is
that's the goals and I think Joe painted
a really good picture of why it's still
important the really you know top-end
players
anytime soon but getting that experience
in game to be able to go look hey I want
to go to the timeline I want to read a
thing I can watch a thing oh and I can
play a thing right like it's one thing
to hear about Kate it's another thing to
play with Kade
for you know a bunch of our new players
is going to be an exciting way to
experience some content um
I like it so can you kind of explain how
fire scene power works for us
yeah so there's there's two ways that
we're really thinking about yeah
Power fixed activities and so this is
stuff like four hours free roam
destination the regular strikes queue uh
the base power of an exotic mission
right which really exciting like we want
to build more serif Shields we want to
build more prestiges and so for a bunch
of this we're going to say even if you
don't have a friend right go into this
bring whatever you want we've adjusted
the difficulty for it to just feel good
to play right and so we know you want to
go around the destination and be able to
One-Shot drags with a hand Cannon we
also want the destination to put up a
little bit of resistance and to feel
like maybe I can't be shot by 15 drags
and so like we're we're dialing in that
power but it was like okay this is a
great like base experience for the story
of final shape the you know that
experience is power fixed so you're
gonna get power upgrades but you don't
have to equip them right right then then
post that or say hey we've got a bunch
of power enabled activities too there's
aspirational stuff the raid the dungeon
trials for this okay I care about power
Enlightenment so uh we've got a an
employee that we like to pick on here A
guy by the name of Matt naguchi who is a
very hardcore Destiny I think that I'm a
hardcore Destiny player and then I look
at my friends list I'm like how is his
past level this high right like
um
uh and so we still want to say Hey you
know you feel like you're rewarded and
engaged
but you can go into Nightfall and let's
say
hey you've been out across the world
doing good deeds you weren't able to
play Destiny for the last three months
and come back and say you know I like
this name but what I really like are
dungeons really like a raids yeah okay
getting Matt naguchi's fire team anyone
that's in you know a pre-made fire team
whether you made this fire team and fire
team finders
who's the highest
okay everyone in here
Five Below no matter what now if you're
if you're close on that great we're
gonna respect your power well I was the
highest guns you have what armor you
have we're gonna say hey we're gonna
take this all up and so you don't have
to worry about
instead I'm like hey go play The Raid
and then go get the new really good raid
weapons right like that's the thing we
want you to be caring about not that you
can't step in the content at all right
focus on the optimization not on the
requirement so I can load in the green
Loadout if you want to uh I mean
listen I put on some armor that can't
take resistance mods and that's a bold
choice
but but doable yeah yeah we will not so
I'm sure we'll see some wacky raid
clears that are like ah I did it all in
the broken parade yeah like you
certainly did
for you
what about with trials it's like the one
kind of like pvps the thing that that uh
yeah so um we know there are some
important reasons to keep uh Power on
the trials and related
um and so right now oh yeah
I have a switch where we're going to say
hey we're gonna you have another game
Power in this because one we want to
make sure that we keep that experience
in a good spot
two like it is an experience where I've
got this friend Shane uh and he is a
Master with golden grunt but he he plays
Destiny off and on I would love to be
able to say Shane we're playing trials
this weekend and I know you haven't
played in a while please just put the
client back on get inside and him just
be able to go and we'll have better
weapons a lot better armor
golden gun and get us two kills every
time and so I I think we do want to
still have that you know experience for
even at the high end of PVP we just want
to make sure we do it right and so it is
something that we are walking in
carefully and saying okay we're gonna
try this we're gonna we're gonna test it
if it doesn't work we're gonna find a
different solution yeah and specifically
we're gonna like I want us to have we
want us to have room to experience
during the episode
and we'll see how it goes he looks like
Bill's doing really well you know we'll
figure out what to do with that next and
if it doesn't we'll figure out if
there's something else we need to try
differently
um but like uh but yeah so I'm excited
to see if it gets more variety of
players into trials and more people who
didn't feel like they could do it before
give it a go which would be interesting
that sounds great
um so kind of on that note the in-game
lfg has been in ask for a long time can
we talk about the fire team finder
experience a little bit more
yeah yeah
um so this is probably just I'm a big
Xbox lfg user like when someone's like
Joe we want to raid this time this day
I'm like I don't know what I'm doing
that time though my desire and rate
experience is that I I log in and I say
I have you know an hour I have two hours
and I'm like I want to read right now so
I'll go to my friends list and if I
don't have friends on to play with I
will go to one of the community run lfgs
um and that's a
there are so many great Services out
there that do this right but for a bunch
of players
they don't understand that exists they
don't have access to this it also it can
be a pretty big uh hurdle to just be
like hey I'm just looking to do the you
know uh Legend version of this activity
I wish I could just go in game and say
I'm not quite comfortable with match
made people but if I can get you in a
group with me we could talk about it no
can we make that fast can we make that
so I just like hey what do I want to do
okay I want to do the news
just give me people and we'll go right
away I'll take the random draw you can
also say no no
give me people and I want to be able to
approve or deny them when they come in
and they say hey it's just somebody oh
okay I uh I'll let uh we talked in chat
I don't think you're the right person
we're gonna wait until we get the people
that we want and so
it's really about striking this balance
of both being customizable for folks
that are like from someone
I'm a guy and a player this is going to
bring so much toxic [__]
but I do like the fact that it's
somebody coming
I do not want to teach right now right
and so I can go in there and I can say
hey I'm looking for people at this
Guardian rank I'm looking for people
that are experience didn't want to go
fast we know that we need to build uh
I'm looking for a group tool that can do
both of those things and so
it's a big step uh these systems are
very challenging and I think we're going
to learn a lot about when it's coming
out that's why we're like this is coming
out in season 23 yes and we are going to
get people looking at this playing this
and we're gonna figure out you know what
happens when the community gets it in
their hands and really make sure that
we're in a good shape for when people
are using this tool to do L-shaped
content yeah and I think I think to
Joe's point from from the beginning it
really democratizes some of that like
Pinnacle experience right like new
players don't know to go out of the game
and look for these these uh these really
legitimately good Community Services but
like you know I think I think a lot of
players stay contained to what's inside
of of the client and we want to make
sure that those players can have the
same grouping experience as the core
fans who've learned how to do it in
those community activities so keep just
a nerd at it but it's a little bit more
um so there's like two ways to enter
into the fire team finder flow there
might actually be a few more like one
there's like a gonna go select fire team
finder from my roster and you're going
to go in there and you're gonna see the
okay do I want to do rage you're going
to pick through this whole flow another
way if you like go click on a raid or a
Carl did you see the CMA stuff going on
the roster oh that's CMA that's crazy
yeah they they Microsoft pretty much
said they made a deal saying that we
won't we're gonna sell our cloud
computing rights to Activision Blizzard
games in the UK the Ubisoft really for
15 years 15 years it will be exclusive
to s-cloud it'll be anywhere and Ubisoft
is the ones that will probably will be
the stewards of it for the first 15
years and this is in the UK yes no this
is in general for all of cloud gaming
shoes like really you said we're not
gonna break that down again all right
okay can I end this oh Jesus
do it that way if you've built
communities that you're
what does this mean for guided James
yeah
uh beta uh you know might eventually be
coming to an end and so I think we want
to we want to make sure we do this in
the right way I know I forgot guided
games
we really see fire team finder as just
the the fully fledged version of how to
find the group and so
um yeah this is definitely the future
go ahead and just issue all those people
finding people with the same desires as
me and a bunch of things that really
guided games couldn't do well yeah is
this the first time you saw anything
about all the uh
I just I woke up and jumped straight on
the street that [__] happened that
[__] three o'clock this morning
I was playing Star fields
Bill supposed to send an internal member
to Microsoft employees discussing the
ABK deal restructuring he Praises Sarah
Bond accepts your leadership and says
the CMA review process should complete
by deal deadline
which is October 18th
all right you guys it was nice but we're
heading in this I don't want to spoil
too much here I think starting with
strange coins
um
what are they going to do get rid of
them
presents more currencies
for newer players they're like oh I
gotta I gotta goes there like we've lost
it with our you know people that play
Destiny every week and so I think one is
putting Zur back into this like you're
gonna be excited about what zurist
telling this week
two it's like going back to Strange
Coins right like this feeling of hey I'm
doing rituals Destiny
PVP getting these things
rewarding options
how's my strange coin purse
uh because certainly right guys you guys
have a nice day I'm in Industry highest
early in Destiny's life